hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
mapping the transparent brain with
idisco clear map
and light sheet imaging i'm alexis
crowles of labyrinth
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinths and
sponsored by
milton e biotech for more information
about our sponsor
please visit their site at
www.miltonybiotech.com now
let's get started i would like to remind
everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click on
the send button
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
ask question box located on the far left
of your screen
i'd like to now introduce our presenters
nicholas vernier
the group leader of the paris brain
institute in paris france
for a complete biography on our
presenter please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen
nicholas you may now begin your
presentation
hello and welcome thank you all for
joining us for this virtual meeting
organized by miltoni
i'm a nikola avenir i'm the head of the
laboratory of structural plasticity in
the price brain institutes
and today i wanted to discuss about
the different applications that we have
of the
tissue clearing and mapping techniques
that we developed
over the past couple of years
and to do that i'm gonna
show you two different um
projects that we are developing in in
the lab
um the first project will be more about
behavior and the second project will be
more about the vasculature of the brain
the first one is not published the
second one is published
and almost all the data that you
you will see today have been acquired
with the ultra microscope
light sheet microscope from lavision
so what is the really the big question
that we
are interested in in our lab
the thing that you're seeing here are
these neurons in the somatosensory
cortex in the brain
we did a very sparse labeling with a
virus
and here you can see the gfp positive
axons projecting
from the sensory cortex to the motor
cortex and here you can appreciate the
complexity of the terminal branches
of these axons so what we want to
understand is uh what are the mechanisms
and the consequences of the plasticity
that could happen
on those terminal branches um
and the reason we are big fans of tissue
clearing and lynch in microscopy is
because we are looking a little bit at
the type of problem that is the needle
in a haystack problem so
if you have axons projecting everywhere
in the brain
from this one region
the problem is if you have different
factors that can influence
the stability of these axonal
projections
and lead eventually to the pruning of
some of these projections
the the thing is if you're only looking
at
one single window like what we can do
in longitudinal studies then you don't
really appreciate what's going on
in the rest of the brain so
there are many many ways that you can
study plasticity in a very small part of
the brain but
if you try to expand this to the whole
brain
it becomes much more complex and this is
where
back in 2013 during my postdoc in the
lab of marquis
levine we started being interested in
pushing forward the development of 3d
imaging to study
axon plasticity in the whole brain
the problem is at this if you're looking
in fixed tissue
you are looking at a endpoint so it
means that
you can not really look at one brain and
retrace the history of what happened to
that brain but
what you can do is hopefully
scan many many brains and then average
those brains to map different features
onto those adverse brain and generic
statistics
so the statistics the statistics could
be the distribution of cells
or active neurons in the brain it could
be tracing
axonal projections and how they might
change
in the different groups that we are
studying or it might be
also looking at how the vascular network
which
supports brain function can change
also during those
changes in activity and so
the key point in the different
techniques that we're trying to develop
to address those questions
is that we need to be able to scan
many many brands for just any single
experiments that we're doing
and generate this average brain and
difference maps
and that's really the key is that to to
scan many brains and analyze them
you need to have extremely reliable and
reproducible protocols
and you need that these protocols enable
the scaling up
in terms of sample numbers and in terms
of the downstream analysis that we're
doing
so for us scaling up in terms of being
able to
do many samples at the same time was
very very important from the beginning
and so for that we developed two
different techniques
uh one is idisco
and now idyscopus which is a nemo
labeling
protocol adapted to adult
samples with the fridisco
endpoint tissue clearing and this
is really an optimized whole sample
adult immunolabeling protocol and the
current protocol has not
really changed since 2016 and this is
still the one that we are using today in
the lab
and we can scan many many different
types of markers
like here for instance tyrosine hydroxyl
very dense
marker and also very sparse markers
so the other technique that we have
is a clear map which we also developed
back at the rockefeller
university so i disco was developed with
zhuhawu
and clear map was developed with
christophe kirst
within the tesla lab and
with clear map we wanted to be able to
really streamline the segmentation
and alignment of the data onto a
reference template in the brain
so what we are doing with clear map
and idscore is for instance map
false positive neurons which gives us a
view into
the cellular activity of the brain
we can also scan a axonal projection
[Music]
labeled with a virus and for instance
here what you are seeing
is an example of um hand annotation of
axons with the software
side glass um that is extremely uh
performance to perf to do hand
annotation of axonal trajectories uh
using a virtual reality helmet
so this is a really nice way to segment
single axon in
extremely sparsely um
labeled brains the other thing that we
can do is if we have
too many axons to segment by hand is um
we can then for instance here you see a
bulk injection into the bowel cortex and
the projections throughout the brain
from the bowel cortex
so this is students to trace manually
and here we can use still the same
software
uh clear map 2 that we developed
recently
or we can use the recently released
trail map from the early childhood lab
so that
actually depends on the structure of the
data we would tend to use train map for
sparser
data or clear map for extremely dense
data
and so here you see the full brain
projection pattern from the bell cortex
and here you can see
an average map produced by clear map
and here the injection sites in the
barrel cortex
so the first project that i'm going to
show you
will apply these two key techniques so
the
cell mapping and the axon mapping to try
to understand
a biological process and how the brain
can
generate dynamic activity and behavior
so what we are studying as one of the
first
projects we started in the lab is the
nesting behavior
and the this thing is extremely
important for many mammals
even in the lab nice and
nesting provides a thermophilic physical
protection
the thing that we're interested in is
that in most animals that are nesting
what is important is that the behavior
has to happen
before the birth of the offspring of
course
and so this is an uh energetically very
costly behavior
but it has to be done without any
obvious external stimuli and so wanting
to understand what
during the pregnancy in mammals can
trigger the onset of this nesting
behavior
without any external triggers
here you can see a an accelerated
timeline
time-lapse movies with on the left side
the virgin mouse and the same mouse a
couple of days later
pregnant and you can appreciate here
how the pregnant mouse is building much
more than the
virgin mouse these cotton pads and so
the question that we ask is really what
happens uh
during the pregnancy and this is
something quite striking
actually because we can score the nest
in
a very simple way with a flat nest in
blue and a hollow nest in red
and we can actually measure
how the mice are building nests every
day so here this is the whole colony in
the lab and
you can see uh most mice are building
blue flat nests and
here when we have a plug onset at here
you can see that uh right after the
meeting the mice start to build a hollow
nest
so that's a very well documented effect
so the thing that's interesting is that
pregnant female are very special
here you can see an event plot of
nesting on several mice so that those
are the virgin mice
so they tend to start nesting and stop
relatively quickly
you can see that if you add a pup and in
a virgin mice then
they also nest uh quite a bit
but then pregnant females are really
completely different
they will extend long nesting belts
for many many minutes at the same time
it's something that you don't really see
in the other groups
you see that pregnant and virgin mice in
shape nesting very fast
and also the thing that makes the
pregnant mice very different
from either the virgin mice or the
virgin that have pubs
is that the pregnant mice will spend
much more time building their nests
so to understand how it works we used
um our clear map method which here you
can see the
scan of the false positive neurons and
we clear the brain once it has been
immunostained
with the force antibodies and then we
generate
um advantage maps we register those maps
and then we compare the groups
so what did we see so
one of the obvious candidate region that
we might have been looking at
if we didn't have access to light sheet
microscopy and unbiased whole brain
mapping
would have been the pre-optic areas
those are very well known to
be involved in nesting and in pop
interaction
in the mice so you can see here that
there's not much more activity
in virgin female mice that are either
not doing anything or building a nest
if you expose the virgin female to a pup
you can see
these green dots mean that there is
significantly more
activity during nesting after the prep
exposure
and here what was nice to see is that if
you take a pregnant female
but which is not in contact with the pup
just pregnant
you can see also this increase in
activity in the lateral creatic area and
the medial pelvic area
so it means that when we add the cotton
to a pregnant female
it sort of stimulates similar regions
than when we add the pup
and the cotton to a virgin female but
then
we really wanted to understand what
makes the pregnant female different
and so we try to look for brain regions
that are
getting activated during parental
nesting during the pregnancy but not
in the other groups and here this is a
scatter plot of all the brain regions
that are significantly more enriched in
the pregnant females
and one of them here the adventure
vessel
we found to be significantly more active
in the pregnantness builder
over the virgin s builder and the
pregnant inactive mice
so that was a really interesting because
the dangerous for nucleus is
not really known to be involved
in urban or behaviors
it's actually mostly known for its role
in
opioid motor control but there are some
evidence that it can also
be active during different types of
a more complex behavior such as social
behavior or stress
here you can see the p values in the
endangered vessels a very tiny nucleus
in the middle of the brain
that is more active only in the pregnant
female building nest
and not in the females exposed to herb
or not in the virgin nest illness
we investigated a little bit more the
role of this nucleus but
what i want to point out at this point
is is that
really how the use of unbiased hormone
mapping
helped us to identify this very small
region
and what we did
is we inhibited using chemogenetic this
nucleus
so you can see here a pregnant female
that is nesting so it's
similar to the first movie that you saw
and here the same female
that receives the clozapine agonist
of the head's inhibitory receptor
you can see that this
female will when the female receives the
cotton
uh unlike the control uh that you see in
the upper frame
the bottom female will actually
stay under the cotton and not really
spend a lot of time building the nest so
if we quantify
that we would see that the
inhibited animals would spend much more
much less time nesting than the
controlled pregnant females
so does that have an impact on the
evolution of nesting
in the pregnancy so to assess that
instead of doing an acute inhibition
we just did the genetic
lesion of the cells so here you see the
edinger vessel
cart positive neurons which are the
normal peptide producing nodes and
after the lesion using a space 3
specific virus so here you see in the
control group the y types that receive
the virus you see the evolution of the
steam
after mating so that's the normal
distribution you would see
and in the mice that have a lesion
you see that really the response of
parental nesting is completely blunted
compared to the control mice
so it really shows that other days these
few neurons that are located at the
center of the brain are really
instrumental in driving this behavior
so if you don't have in the adventure
vessel nucleus you don't really
have this transition towards parental
nesting
so we're trying to understand really now
how it works
so here this is a we took all the data
that we had
for the behavior and we try to
see how much time the mice spend nesting
uh in the movies and then with the light
sheet data
how many uh positive neurons we had for
c
force in the edinger base for nucleus
and we do that correlation
and represent the data into a tsne plot
so here it means that the brain regions
which are represented by circle that are
close to each other
um it means that the they vary
together in the behavior data so
here what you have are clusters of
cortical
neurons brain stem neurons and
hypothalamic neurons and that
data did not really show us exactly what
the
danger of a soul could be controlling
because funnily enough the danger of s4
is really in the middle of all those
regions in the
tsne scatter plot so it means really
they are
sort of halfway through the control of
all these regions that we spawned
during nesting so to better understand
what's going on we turned
to mapping the projection of this
nucleus so here this is an example so we
use the card cree
lined which label doesn't wound so you
can see the ones in red here and you can
see
the projection once a little bit
everywhere in the brain
so those axons
you can see them here in the raw data
with the light sheet scan
but we can actually
using clear map or using trail map and
in that case both of them are good
um you can map the location of all those
axons throughout the brain and then try
to do statistics
so here this is what we saw which is a
little bit complex so you see the
density of projections
a little bit throughout the brain so a
lot in the hypothalamus
not very dense in the cortex but also
very dense in the brain stem
and in the mean brain you have some hot
spots like the superior colliculus and
inferior curriculus
and um but many many targets in the
hypothalamus
so to try to to understand what could be
the important targets of the edinger
base for nucleus
during nesting what we did
is we compared the
degree of activation that you see in
chemogenetic when you activate the
adidas
nucleus so we activated the nucleus and
we mapped the
c4 cells using light sheet microscopy
and clear map
and then we map the density of
projection and we correlate
how much the region responds to the
activation
and how many projections that
we should receive and here you can see
that one of them pulls apart
really far away which is the socratic
nucleus
which is here in if you see my pointer
it receives a lot of projections from
the angiography nucleus and
respond a lot both during natural
nesting behavior or during
chemogenetic activation of the angel vs4
neurons so the rest of the story is more
related to
the physiology of what happens so it's
not really directly related to relative
data so i'm gonna leave it
there for this talk which is more
dedicated
to the use of like sheep microscopy but
just to give you a quick summary
we can we were able using light
microscopy to
address a complex question
a complex biological question which was
to identify
what are the neurons responding to this
um
nesting during this testing behavior
specifically in pregnant females so it
means
being able to scan about 40 to 50
mouse brains and that's the work of
really a single uh talented student
tomato pico
uh so meaning that those techniques they
really enable
just one student or one person one
experimenter
to just be very productive and scan
a lot of samples and do a lot of
analysis
and then combining the activity mapping
with external
mapping enable us to generate hypotheses
as to
how those networks might function and
then to test those hypotheses using uh
more standard
techniques of neural physiology
so the next point that i wanted to touch
base on was the work that we recently uh
published on
mapping the the vasculature of the mouse
brain
um so this is something that was really
of interest to us because we are trying
to understand
how the axonal plasticity can
interact with the vascular plasticity
and we think that both of them might go
together because of course if you're
changing
activity levels of neurons you might
want to
have to readjust how the
supply to these neurons is done
so the
sort of gold standard of a
reconstruction of vascular network was
done uh for instance in the group of
david kleinfeld and here the beautiful
work
from um psy and blender uh to
reconstruct
really and analyze the the best culture
but
the problem is those data sets are
extremely hard to get
they are very good quality but very hard
to get and also they
encompass just a finite region of the
brain
so we that was really a heroic work from
uh five persons in the lab
christophe cursed really was uh pushing
forward this project
and we had to make an alba from the lab
and as well as sophie and paul
assisting facetime to be able to
perform high throughput reconstruction
of the vasculature
something that was very important to us
is that we would be able
to also annotate veins and arteries
because if you don't have the veins and
arterial venous and arterial information
then it's it's a little bit limiting
what you can do with those
data and those information so
the the thing also that we wanted to do
is to
uh avoid the rely on uh
dye injection so most methods to label
the vasculature we
will use intracardiac or tail vein
the injections and the the problem with
those techniques is that
you have to discard a lot of animals
when the injections are not
well done and there's some skills in
doing those injections that are
a little bit hard to reproduce so we
used exclusively in no labeling so the
idea is that
if you have good antibodies then the
whole cohort should be
labeled the same way so by using cd31
and podocalexia and smooth methylactin
you can generate
a nice whole brain in the labeling of
the vasculature
throughout all the different scales and
the smooth muscle acting will label
very strongly the arterioles and very
frankly the veins
which by combining the information of
a signal level and radii we can
discriminate between veins and arteries
so that's the type of
image data that we get from this um
scan uh using uh again the the ultra
microscope
so you can see the large surface
arteries and the
large surface veins which are very weak
in this constant selecting
and then inside the panchima you can see
the
capillaries materials and videos
so if i take you through that movie a
little bit further so you can see here
the cerebellum is beautiful
um for instance you can see that in the
end we
generate a graph reconstruction
of this network
which is an annotated reconstruction and
so how do we do that
so the first thing that we had to solve
was that
we need to have a perfect alignment of
the data and
since we are traveling over very wide
ranges
with the latching microscope it can
happen that you have some mechanical
jitter
in the middle of the scan that can lead
to a misalignment
locally of the vessels as you can see
here
so here you can see that above the tile
is very well aligned and below is well
aligned but
there was one part in the z progression
where the motor moved a little bit
and then you have this misalignment and
that is i must say our microscope is on
an air table and the air table itself is
on an air table
so it's very well isolated we still have
these mechanisms
so we've wrote the wobbly stitcher
within a clear map that can do a plane
wise realignment of the data
and do a whole brain
adjustment with a global optimization
which enables
a better continuous
tracing of the vessels then
what you see here is that actually the
signal to noise ratio is quite good in
this data
but it's quite complex because you have
very big vessels that have a halo
and you have small capillaries and so
there are two different ways you can
address this you can either do a deep
normal network
or you can generate different filters to
reconstruct the different parts of that
signal
so we decided to not use a different
network for
this one because we felt like it was
still a case where we could use
just uh parametric filters and
parametric filters are nice because you
don't need to train them so you can
tweak
them and reapply them on different types
of data
while deep neural network can do
impressive
things but you cannot really translate
the neural network on
widely different types of data so you
will have to retrain them
often so here we use the situation tubes
equalization and the convolution to
capture the different parts of the
signal in those data
and it works on this very very large 400
gigabyte
data 400 gigabyte is a half brain so one
terabyte for the whole brain
then the last thing that we needed to
fix was that
since we are labeling only the walls of
the vessels
um it means that in the
mask that we are generating those
vessels are empty
because they are not filled with a dye
so we needed to
virtually fill them so then we had to
use a deep neural network to recognize
these hollow structures and fill them
um we tried more simple techniques for
the feeling
but that could not work so there we had
to develop
our network which fills the whole tubes
and then
we developed a super fast uh centerline
extraction
algorithm that can in one hour
do 3d thinning on the whole mask to
extract the center line so that's the
whole pipeline
i invite you to look at the paper if you
want to have more details
on the organization of this pipeline but
this
is the the final result so we
implemented
in the python code of clear map 2 which
is available online
3d visualization toolbox which enable us
to
plot all the vessels that are
reconstructed in the brain
so here the color of the capillaries are
the brain regions
and the arteries are in
dark red and the veins are in dark blue
so
this is a graph object so it means that
you can really run computation
on the graph directly this is a view of
the spinal cord you can remove the
capillaries to
see what's left with the veins and
arteries
[Music]
you can flip the graph in all the
directions that you want and we plot
in any direction you can also for the
rest of the brain remove the capillaries
to see only the veins and the arteries
and you can also run computation on this
graph so the whole length
that we measure in the half brain is 144
meters in
average uh distributed like this so you
can see that
the cortex and hippocampus takes up
about one-third of the length of vessels
in the brain and then
the brain stem is actually
almost over one third of what's left
with the striatum hypothalamus and the
brain being
a little bit less than one third all
combined
you can see the single regions and here
the waves that you see
are the cortical layers that where you
see always a peak
in the layer 4 in the sensory regions
you can calculate distances between
arteries
and veins here we see that
most vessels are located within five
branch point of the nearest artery and
within seven branch point of the nearest
name
um and we can see that this is quite
homogeneous between the different brain
regions so that's actually
seems to be a constant throughout the
brain this distance between veins and
atoms
even though the density itself is
different
what we did also is automated
classification of
the region based on the density and
orientation
of the vessels in the cortex here what
you can see is that
motor and integrative region tend to
cluster together while
sensory regions tend to cluster together
and this is mostly driven by the fact
that
sensory region have actually a very
nuclear organization
in the upper cortical layers where you
see
radially oriented a lot of radially
oriented vessels
in the upper cortical layers that we
think
help to bring the blood faster to the
layer 4 which receives the dynamic input
so
all of this you can really already see
on the graphs that we are generating
of the vasculature and what we are using
this data
for in the lab is to study
the plasticity of the vesiculature after
sensory depolarization
so what you see here is that actually
the sensory region
of the grain and especially the layer 4
are
hot spots at all the different relays so
you see that the somatosensory cortex
here but also
the vpn which is the dynamic relay the
mgn
which is the telomeric relay of the
auditory cortex and in the brainstem
all the different sensory relays they
have a
high density of vessels
that's um something that of course
already known
um but we felt like this is interesting
because then we can
try to see what happens when you deprive
of sensory inputs so the ultimate goal
is to do that in adult animals but here
we had started
doing it in mice that were
continentally deaf so meaning they have
never heard
of their whole life so the system
develops without any sensory inputs
so what you see using so that's a
collaboration with the lab of christine
30
and nicola michelski at the pastel
institute
you can see that here the autophagy
mutant have a
decrease in branch point densities
in the auditory cortex this is also seen
here by these
average heat maps of vessel densities
and you can see here the statistical map
that shows a reduction in branch point
densities in the auditory cortex the
primary
and the posterior and also auditory
cortexes
so that was already published and that
was actually uh
described already by several groups that
are in
in deaf animals you have less blood
vessels in the auditory cortex
the thing that we could also see because
it's a brain-wide
analysis is that you also have these
reductions into the sensory relays at
different parts of the brain so here the
cochlear nucleus
the nucleus of the lateral lemniscus and
the intracoaliculus and the lateral
superior olive um so
what you also see here which is
interesting is that here the
the auditory relay has a decrease in
branch point densities but
the somatosensory relay does not have a
decrease
in benchmark densities but if you look
in the cortex
you see that actually there is an
increase of
branch point densities in
the cortical
region receiving input from the
somatosensory
system so here the whiskers all the face
and so this is something quite striking
that
in these deaf animals you have a
decrease in
the audition
at all the different relays but only in
the cortex you
we see an increase in the branch point
density so it means that there is
some peculiar plasticity in the
vesiculature of the cortex that could
happen
maybe actually after the closure of the
critical periods because
the closure of the critical period in
the auditory cortex happens
much later than the closure of a
clinical player than the somatosensory
context so that suggests that
there may be some more complex uh
plastic
events going on in the vasculature that
has been
uh anticipated from previous studies so
this is just a very
specific application uh that we wouldn't
want that i wanted to highlight of our
work on the basic lecture but really to
see how
um we can now relatively easily generate
uh very complex data sets that are maybe
the
histological equivalent of
rna sequencing but for anatomy because
now we can really go throughout the
whole anatomy
in an unbiased way and pick out the
interesting hotspot of
changes so
uh the techniques that i presented you
today are idisco
plus uh that we developed with uh
zhuhawu
and um also a clear map
that enables us to
re-reconstruct those data throughout the
brain we'll be
happy to help you implement those
techniques if you're interested
um qmap is available on github
you can go on idscode.info for more
information or you can contact us
directly via email
and here it's just um
like a quick view of some of the members
of the lab not everyone was there for
this picture but
i really wanted to highlight the work of
uh tomato pico uh on the
mouse nesting project and alba sophie
and christoph
for the vasculature project and also
really thank our collaborators nicola
michelski for sympathy
piato topico and guess margaret
schenfeld for this project
and thank you so much for tuning in in
this
difficult time to watch some science um
and uh we are looking for post docs so
if you don't know where to go um in
these difficult times um the lab is open
and
ready to welcome you um
and i will be here online uh
also to answer your questions so don't
hesitate to ask all the questions that
you have
or to contact me later bye and i'll see
you on the chat
thank you nicolas for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
so let's get started our first question
is
you mentioned two software tracing
programs approaches
one for dense material and the other
four
and more discrete processes can you tell
the names or
labs responsible for that software again
right so first off i would like to thank
everyone
for sticking around to the end of the
talk and for the
live q a um so for the first question
about the the type of algorithm that we
use or software that we use to trace
axons uh it's actually a um
quite good question because there's no
silver bullet there so
and it actually changes uh very rapidly
so
as you understood correctly um when we
have
extremely sparse data sets so for
instance only one neuron is labeled in
the whole brain
then we really like to use virtual
reality because you can manually trace
very effectively the axons there so we
we like this commercial software called
side glass vr
then if you want to reconstruct bulk
axons it actually depends the the
density of the the projections
so there's the very good network that
was published recently
by the lab of lucindo trail map which is
publicly available now which works
really well for medium density
of axons but will tend to fail more
for extremely high densities and so for
extremely high densities of axons then
we like to use our own tool
uh clear map too so i
i hope that would answer the
the question
now moving on to our next question what
computing power does one need for clear
map two
and two maps ram grfx card
right so it depends exactly what you
want to do so
if you want to reconstruct
um so yeah so if you want to reconstruct
a cell position then actually you don't
need much
a standard computer with maybe
gigabytes of ram would be enough then if
you want to
use it for the vasculature this is where
you actually need to scale
up and have a bigger computer and there
it depends uh what the size of the data
that you want to reconstruct
if you want to reconstruct like we did
the the brain of the mouse
so you would be generating that effect
of
about 500 gigabytes to one terabyte
for this uh you want to have at least
256 gigabytes of ram on your computer
and uh you may want to also have
a kuda capable graphics card so for
instance an nvidia
graphics card i'd be happy to
answer more precise questions but you
can already start with a smaller
configuration and then scale up
depending on the size of the
data
now nikolas have you tried these
techniques with rats
right so that's a that's a very good
question because um
there is a so there's no technical
difficulty
of working with rats in terms of
labeling the tissue imaging is a little
bit more complicated because
we cannot really fit well the right
brain into the working distance
of the objective so you would have to do
um only a piece of the red brain maybe
one half
of the red brain under the standard
division levision ultra microscope
but then there's a bigger even challenge
for the
the rat which is that we are lacking a
very precise
annotation at last from the erlenberg
institute for the rat brain which
is an amazing resource that we have for
the mouse brain
and um unfortunately
as long as we don't have a reference at
last for the right brain
we'll be very limited in the type of
analysis that we can do on the right
brain
so we're definitely waiting for this
resource to be available in the future
is clear map different from software
like amira or amaris
yes so um clear map is actually uh
very different in a way that this is
amirah or imaris
are a generalistic tools so you
you will buy for a lot of money uh those
uh software
and then you can use them to for many
different types of questions
the thing with a clear map is that it's
extremely focused
on the very precise application that i
showed
during the talk meaning location of
positive nuclei in the brain tracing of
axon location and the reconstruction of
the vasculature so everything that is
outside of this
particular application uh would not be
feasible with clear maps but we are
looking forward to add more specific
application and that's actually
the development model that we chose for
uh clear map which is that we want to be
focused on
specific applications where we think
that we can really
add something over the commercial tools
but uh we also actually on the side use
emirates for
other things that we're doing in the lab
so i see them
as more complementary
we've gotten so many great questions in
today we want to thank our audience for
that so let's go to
the next one
so for our next question
you mentioned a paper by liquin lao and
cursed in 2020
where was that work published
yeah so this is published in pms um
and the code is also regularly available
on github
and the link is in the pns paper
great nicholas can you use any
antibodies for whole brain labeling
and how do you validate your antibodies
uh right so actually that's the most
important
uh factor when we are uh trying a new
application
for idisco is the validation of the
antibodies so
unfortunately not every antibody will
perform well
with idisco so actually most of the
development
time that we spend before even getting
to
having those images is validating the
antibodies
so the the best way to to validate the
antibodies is first to start with
antibodies that already perform really
well on sections
because if it doesn't work on section
there's absolutely no chance that you
can push this into a 3d application
and then we start by actually testing
the antibodies on the
limited sample size so for instance you
would take
a one millimeter slab of
tissue and then you can test the
antibody on these
tissue thick sections and
get a very good feeling in about only
two days of diffusion
of what's the diffusion rate of this
antibody
so the the thing that is very important
is to use
a very high quality uh antibodies that
give very low background and of target
staining
so it really pays off to spend a lot of
time
testing different references
and our next question why did you use
idisco instead of clarity or other
clearing techniques
yeah so originally we developed
id score because we
felt that clarity had a lot of
shortcoming in terms of
the immunoreactivity of different
stainings
um so for instance uh
one of the first applications we wanted
to do was to label for first
cells and the antibody that we were
using
could not work with clarity so
originally we developed ibisco because
it's actually
mimicking very closely the traditional
immunohistochemical protocol that were
actually already available for the past
20 or 30 years so
our goal was really to not use a
hydrogel embedding which
actually have some values for certain
applications but for straight up in no
labeling
we found that it was not necessary and
in some cases was actually harmful to
the quality
of the results so this is why we are
doing everything with ibsco
now can you address the uniformity of
staining in the cleared tissue with the
vascular mapping example
looking at your cd31
staining it appeared that there was a
pronounced gradient from the pile
surface of the brain extending in
are there ways to mitigate this
non-anatomical staining
so the gradient of
the antibodies are an unfortunate
consequence of us usually not waiting
long enough to homogenize that gradient
throughout the the brain so to be
realistic
we usually you know labels between one
and two weeks
and then uh that can lead to a gradient
so
that type of uh gradient what we what we
do is we validate
first that we are not missing
information due to this gradient so
meaning that
we still have positive structures
labeled at the center of the brain but
then
it means that we have implemented into
clear map2
corrective algorithms in the forms of
histogram equalization and normalization
so that the signal at the center of the
brain which is weaker than the signal at
the pl surface
would be um revealed at the
the same and quantified with the same
rate as what we see
on the surface so this is actually one
of the reason why the
clear map ii filter type line is
actually quite complex because if you
are looking into the publication um
that came out in february of qmap 2 um
in cell
you can see that the arrangement of the
filter is actually meant to deal with
this
very wide variation of signal that we
get from the surface
down to the center of the brain
there is one way to mitigate this
which we are now uh exploring more and
more
uh and that actually might answer some
of the
questions uh which is the use of
monoclonal conjugated antibodies
so the staining gradient is much less
visible with monoclonal
antibody and so now we are
actually moving into this direction for
very highly expressed epitopes
and that actually help us to mitigate
the gradient effect
we've received so many great questions
today so we do have time for a few more
but i do want to remind our audience
that the questions we are unable to
answer today and those that come in
during the on-demand period
will be answered by nicholas via the
email address that you provided at the
time of registration
so let's move on to another question
for our next question have you
considered
nano antibodies llama or camel for
example
um yeah that's a great question so
actually it's a good follow-up from
what i was just mentioning on monoclonal
antibodies
we were actually quite hopeful to get
camel antibodies or small nanobodies to
work
with idisco and actually they do work
and they diffuse quite well
um the issues that we had with these
antibodies
is because maybe of the small size
there is not a lot of fluorophore that
can be functionally
coupled as of today at least in the ones
that we tested from
for instance from chromotec um
[Music]
there are not a lot of fluorophore
coupled to these antibodies and so
in the end um we
end up using um
the full size igg uh instead because
uh we found that they are much brighter
and they
they give us a better signal than the
nanobodies and the camel
antibodies
idisco utilizes the organic solvents
dibenzyl ether dve
can it be substituted to a more
eco-friendly solvent
uh yeah so that's a that's a good
question so we like to use a
dbe because um it actually gives a very
very good
optical clearing but there are other
options
um the option that is very popular right
now
is to use um ethel uh
cinemato um if your cinemate was
actually proposed as an alternative to
dbe and um what we
recommend is actually to use a steeler
the diamond deleter during the clearing
protocol
so in a very small amount just
for instance five milliliters that are
necessary to
uh homogenize the sample but then you
can do your imaging
into atl cinnamate which is
uh much less toxic than dde apparently
and
if you pre-equilibrated the samples
indeed
before going to a two cinemates at least
that's our experience with the mouse
brain
then you get actually a very comparable
imaging quality
than if you were to image directly in
dbe
and now what are the beneficial features
using idisco
compared to other tissue clearing
methods
um yes so that that's a very common uh
question
um so what i would say is that usually
people
should use the protocol that works best
in their hands
uh and that actually will depend on
what type of microscope you have access
to
so the what i want to say first is that
ibisco plot is
an immuno labeling only technique so we
are not
imaging the natural fluorescence of gfp
rfd with id school isco is only
to be used with antibodies
then the advantage of idisco is that it
mimics
very closely the type of behavior that
you can expect from antibodies
compared to what you get from standard
histology so
we we found that if you are a lab that
is centered around immunohistochemistry
then i discover
is actually a good choice then the only
the other thing is it depends on what
type of microscope you have access to
if you are using the lavision
system for instance the advantage of
using a disco-based technique so it
could be idisco
or udisco or vdisco or all these
techniques or adipoclear whatever
so the advantage is that we are using a
very
cheap and widely available imaging
solution that is extremely stable
unlike when you have to use aqueous
imaging solutions
that are a little bit more complex to
use in this type of microscope
so that's my very very short
take on this very complex question
but i'd be happy to discuss more
if you if you want about the differences
between
all these techniques
great so let's find another question
so for our next question is the cfos
straining
performed on whole brains or do you have
to section the brain
yes the c first technique is really
performed on the whole brain
um so there we don't have to section the
brain and that's
the the the the very nice thing of using
tissue clearing and light sheet
microscopy is
really to study the the sample
completely intact
so there's absolutely no sectioning in
none of the data that i was
showing
so our next question there's a couple
parts to this question
so what is your antibody straining proto
protocol for idisco
antibody concentrations antibody
straining time
antibody uniformity across whole brain
tissue
yeah so for the
for the protocol i invite you to connect
to the id idscode.info website
where you'll have a detailed protocol
which is
up to date to the latest modifications
and the concentration of the antibody is
actually
the most important parameter but has to
be adjusted
uh specifically for each batch of the
antibody so usually we use a
standard concentration of around three
right microgram per milliliter
to for the stainings so we always start
with this concentration three microgram
per milliliter
which is usually about one thousand uh
dilution from the stock that the vendor
will sell you
but we strongly encourage people to
fine-tune
this concentration and test a more
different
concentration if you find you that you
have a lot of
surface background
so let's look for our next question
how is activity detected in in the fixed
brains
yeah so activities that was uh
it's sort of a sterile gate of activity
uh
it is detected with uh the force
immunostaining
and so stands to be expressed when
neuron
will change their activity pattern
usually following a certain stimulation
so there's a whole field of work that is
uh
using foot as a surrogate for brain
activity
on fixed samples so it is obviously not
exactly the normal activity but it gives
you a landscape of
what were the major changes
in the activity landscape in the brain
about
30 minutes to an hour before we actually
sacrificed the the animal so
this is a relatively standard way of
surveying uh changes in activity in the
brain
in space specifically in behavioral
sciences
thank you again nicholas uh do you have
any final comments for our audience
um no i would just like to to thank
everyone who stayed for the
the talk and also for the the questions
i'm
really sorry if we didn't get the time
to answer
all the the questions so we have still a
great list of questions
so if you your question was not answered
really feel free to contact me via email
i'd be happy to
keep discussing and um
also i'd be glad to hopefully
meet everyone interested in our
technologies in a workshop or in the
next
meeting when the conditions are back to
do these
in-person meetings again
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
and like nicholas said questions we did
not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information that you provided at
the time of registration
we would like to once again thank
nicolas for his time today and for his
important research
we'd also like to thank lovers and our
sponsor miltoni biotech for underwriting
today's educational webcast
you can view the webinar on demand
laboratory
email when it is available for replay
that's all for now
thank you and until next time goodbye